MMM,
yeah,
we all,
all of us have a creative process and
part of it is the structure that the
advertising business itself gives us.
You know,
we,
we do what we call a strategic document
and that document gives us all the
bricks that we need to build a house.
It's like the architecture plan to build
a house,
but then eventually it all comes down to
you and your partner.
We always work in teams.
Our art director,
person in a writing person together.
Although those lines are blurred now and
then we sit down at 11:00 at night in
our offices trying to think of something
really brilliant that nobody else has
thought of before and that process
usually involves drinking a lot of water
and going to the bathroom because when
you go to the bathroom,
either in the bathroom or in the shower,
it's the one time you actually let your
brain relax enough to think of something
for you.
Otherwise,
if you're too stressed out and you're
working so hard to think of something,
your brain just kinda closes up on you.
So we have a lot of water in the agency
and every single time somebody comes
back from the bathroom,
they always say,
always,
always say when they come in the door,
I have an idea.
It might not be the best idea or the
idea,
but it's an idea.
And it usually we feed on each other's
ideas and that's how we build a and get
to where nobody else has been.